hey what is going on YouTube now as a
youtuber there's a lot of weird things
that we hear about us that we never get
to address now the reason why most
youtubers don't talk about this is
because a lot of youtubers want to be PC
you know I don't even consider myself a
youtuber I never did this [__] in the
first place thinking that it was gonna
go somewhere crazy where I was gonna
make money off of this I just wanted to
make funny videos it's different
nowadays when people make youtube videos
people make it for-profit they want to
be famous they want to get recognized
blah blah blah blah blah well my fellow
peers on YouTube I got your [__] back
because I know that you don't want to
tarnish your reputation but my [__]
reputation [__] up anyways people
think I'm angry people think I'm a [__]
people think I'm mean I'm rude I talked
too much hashtag [__] your feelings one
of the reoccurring things that I've
heard people say about youtubers is this
well I heard through somebody else then
when they met this youtuber they were a
[__] dick why is it that every time I
go around I hear that about some
youtuber they were a [__] dick they
were mean to them they didn't do this
they didn't do that for me oh shut up
[__] I'm gonna tell you a little
personal story and why this topic is
coming up now I've been for multiple
times and it was for different clubs and
sometimes it's for the same event so
when I was in we were at this
after-party right and so as we were
chilling we were having a couple of
drinks one of the students came up to me
that brought me out there and said yo
man I heard this dude over there talking
[__] about you saying that you were a
[__] [__] to him the last time you
were in I'm thinking to myself like I'm
a pretty cool dude I'm pretty nice you
know I'm really cordial especially if
people are gonna fly me out to do a show
I'm extremely respectful kind of got
curious and I looked over I was like huh
who is this person and only for about
two seconds I realized through that guy
was so a show that I did I forgot which
school it was but they flew me out
literally I think just to hang out it
was like in some corner cafe I think I
did a song and I walked offstage you
know and then that's perfectly fine now
literally when you bring me out to these
shows I'm literally yours I'm here to
make you entertain and I'm here to kind
of just chill and kick in and if you
guys want to get to know me I also want
to get to know you and sparkup great
conversation so I get taken to an
after-party which I think was a frat
house filled with boys no girls
a couple of beers and everybody was
playing Smash Brothers which
once again is not that bad I really
don't give a [__] but the reason why
this guy was remembered is because I
remember him because he was standing in
a [__] corner not saying [__] the
dude stood there not saying anything the
whole [__] night so I remember
talking to the dude like yo man why
don't you relax loosen up a little bit
only thing he did was I don't know I'm
still your - that's your reason for
calling me a [__] [__] because I
came up to you had a conversation and
asked you while you were standing around
that's conversation you dumb [__] and
this is what I mean you meet a youtuber
and he falls short of your [__]
expectations or the conversations that
you thought you were gonna have with him
and now we're the [__] [__] I'm a
nice [__] you dumb I'm the
nicest [__] you ever [__] me
get the [__] out my face number one just
because you expect us to act a certain
way we are not your puppet we are not
your [__] toys oh no I am the same
[__] person that you see in these
videos nothing has changed none of this
[__] is a front this is not a [__]
prank channel where I write do these
fake social experiments to tug on your
[__] hearts tree we are unapologetic
for being who we are
I am sorry wait that doesn't make any
sense number two here is something that
seems to just go look yeah you're right
there's a possibility I was a [__]
[__] - you probably because you were
a [__] [__] it's a possibility
that when I meet a stranger for the
first time that I never met you can say
something stupid where I'm thinking hey
[__] you you disgusting wart on a
nutsack I hope that dinosaurs come back
alive specifically the t-rex to see you
in the middle of a field taking a [__]
so you can't even run away and he chops
your body in half shits you out and puts
it in the urn and shows your family if I
was mean to you when we met in person
honestly is probably because you said
something stupid and I didn't like you
that's right is the possibility why is
it so uh why should I not like you why
why why if you don't like me as a person
I'm sorry I don't know what to tell you
I don't know what you were expecting cuz
you've been watching this channel and
I've been a dumb [__] since day one if
you want to be treated with respect you
better treat other people respect too
you get what you got coming to you
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo that's all I'm
saying I love you guys please don't
unsubscribe
[Music]